All right, you guys ready?
Agency fees, which are
the fees non-members are forced to pay
unions for representation in some states –
and the Abood precedent that allows them –
could both be scrapped when the Supreme Court hears Janus versus AFSCME. So why
the fight over agency fees? Unions call
these fees "fair share fees" because
everybody covered by a union-negotiated
contract has to pay for representation.
The fees are typically two-thirds of
full membership dues, and they aren't
supposed to support unions' political
activities, balancing freedom of
expression with the need to prevent free
riders. The petitioner, Janus, argues that
agency fees infringe on freedoms of
speech and association, claiming it's
impossible to separate unions' political
and non-political functions when union
bargaining with the government is
inherently political. For Janus, it's not
about the money – it's about compelled
speech. "Stare decisis" is a legal
principle that makes overturning
precedents rare, but many court watchers,
including unions, expect the conservative
justices will overturn Abood. Whether
the court decides agency fees are an
appropriate balance or compelled speech
will have a major influence on the
future of America's unions.
For more on Janus, agency fees, and why they are so important for teachers union membership,
check the links in the description below.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.